bonjour et bienvenue sur my first alors
l'intuition c'est quelque chose dont on
a pas mal parlé dans les dernières
vidéos et je vous ai jamais vraiment
donné de définition même assez peu
rigoureuse et pour homme et pour cause
parce que j'ai bien peur qu'on est tous
des déficiences est différente de
l'intuition et que c'est pas très claire
ce qui donnait une définition il y
aurait une grosse partie d'entre vous
qui seraient pas d'accord
donc on a tous à peu près une petite
vision parce que c'est l'intuition n'est
pas tous d'accord sur les détails et
pour aujourd'hui selon j'aimerais vous
parler c'est de la manière dont les
mathématiciens parle souvent de
l'intuition qui est je pense un petit
peu différente de la manière dont la
plupart des gens on parle d'intuitions
notamment on va faire ça sous l'angle un
petit peu de psychologie expérimentale
et les travaux nous avons des daniel
kahneman et amos tversky sinon pour ceux
qui se demandent je suis au maroc est en
train de monter le mont tout cas là où
tu peux du mal avec eux c'est louis
daniel kahneman et de amos nord qui sait
qu'on en fait deux modes de pensée au
système rapide système lent il appelle
aussi system un système de wiki grosso
modo correspondent à l'intuition et la
raison est en gros ne vote par défaut
c'est plus intuition de systèmes 1 qui
très rapide très actif c'est là que
lorsqu'on se s'investit vraiment dans un
effort intellectuel que l'on passe en
systèmes de avec la raison est que
savoir des arguments pleurer donné on
pourrait croire que du tout tout ce qui
induit sion c'est mauvais mais c'est pas
du tout en fait le point du propos sur
l'intuition en fait le poids ne sait pas
que l'intuition et mauvais fait mon
intuition charles c'est très très très
bien c'est ce qui permet d'avoir des
réponses rapidement des questions
difficiles et c'est pour ça qu'on
utilise beaucoup dans la vie de tous les
jours et qu'il faut utiliser pour pas
prendre le temps de réflexion sur
n'importe quoi par exemple civ
on a train de marcher en montagne faux
parce que la question à chaque pas ou
est ce qu'on aime exactement le pied
quelles sont les causes mécaniques pour
que notre système de notamment puissent
réfléchir à autre chose ou simplement
pourquoi pas que ce soit trop fatigant
de réfléchir donc la puissance et c'est
vraiment très très bien et c'est aussi
très bien en mathématiques parce que
souvent ça permet de court circuiter
certains abonnements en dix ans pour
voir hâtivement ça ça va pas marcher du
coup on tente pas où est utilement ça
s'appelle intéressant du coup on va voir
s'intéresser davantage à sa déclaration
permet de nous quitter
de prime abord même si intuition se
trompent sont le plus souvent que la
raison ça veut pas dire qu'il ne faut
pas l'écouter davantage leur intuition
comme quoi c'est qu'elle était fourni
des réponses rapidement il faut utiliser
intuition mais souvent le problème est
dans la manière donc beaucoup plus tiède
intuition c'est que malheureusement on
ne fait pas assez attention à quel point
on doit faire confiance
on peut faire une intuition jacques en
fait ce qui manque beaucoup en général
c'est cette prudence vis-à-vis dans
l'addition
ça veut dire qu'il faut tout et de
toutes conditions d'exécution lesquels
on peut avoir comme bien souvent
encombré la recherche en mathématiques
et des choses on n'a pas démontré
assuré qu'il en sera du digeon mais en
fait on est quasiment sûr le besoin
vraiment de démontrer tout de suite et
on va pouvoir se concentrer sur voir une
autre difficulté compter occasion de
résoudre cette difficulté d'aimer
quasiment sûr qu'en fait c'est juste une
difficulté technique
l'intuition permet de sauter des étapes
eux nos réflexions sur lesquels on
pourra revenir plus tard si vraiment
c'est une piste pertinente par exemple
al'inverse via des intuitions week-end
hépatiques et mortimer d'être ouais mais
n'est pas sûr et c'est à ce moment là
parce qu'on essaie de sortir
l'artillerie lourde
on a tous eu l'intuition de couple et
essayer justifier leurs croyances
puissions bref section retenir c'est que
toutes vos intuitions des semaines
aurait certaines de nos auditions sont
beaucoup plus viable vu d'autres et qui
se sont vraiment à remettre en cause en
tout cas fiez vous devriez pas avoir
degré de confiance très important il
faut faire super gaffe à la confiance
que l'on attribue à nos différentes
intuition il ya certaines intuitions
dans lesquelles c'est tout à fait sensé
d'attribuer une grande confiance assez à
ses intuitions
il yad'autres intuition qui sont plus
discutables et sentir qu'elle est le
niveau de confiance attribuée aux
différentes conditions
quant aux différentes institutions je
dirais que c'est quelque chose de très
très très très important et ça m'amène à
un autre point qui est le fait que les
intuitions évoluent les intuitions se
corrige s'améliore si possible se
dégradent eu parfois des intuitions que
vous aviez il ya dix ans ne sont pas les
mêmes que les anti sans que j'avais
maintenant et je dirais même que le gros
du travail du mathématicien le plus
intéressant en fait dans toutes les
mathématiques en tout cas à mon sens
c'est surtout bien travailler nos
intuitions bien amélioré autant que vos
cils nos intuitions
c'est pour ça qu'on adore les trucs
contre intuitif en maths c'est parce que
ça permet de nous de remettre en cause
souvent ça va être un exemple qui va
être intéressant et méditer est derrière
cet exemple eh ben on va pouvoir penser
différemment certains objets que l'on
pensait
toujours d'une certaine manière et à ce
moment là ça peut ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives et surtout ça peut corriger
intuition que l'on avait et au fait là
je suis arrivé au refuge de toubkal qui
est 3200 m il reste encore bon 900
mètres presque 1000 mètres de dénivelé
avant d'arriver au sommet des motos call
avec recul mondial et optiques et un
joli lever de soleil
le truc important en retenir c'est que
les artistes y ont évolué autres il faut
absolument être conscient une évolution
de nos intuitions ou qu'elles sont en
fusion et pour cela il faut absolument
être conscients de l'origine de vos
intuitions france notamment pour mesurer
le degré de confiance que l'on doit
attribuer à une combe d'intuition il
faut essayer d'en déterminer l'origine
ou alors vraiment avoir travaillé pour
avoir réfléchi pendant longtemps sur le
degré de confiance qu'il faut attribuer
à différentes conditions c'est vraiment
la clé il a drivé mr
et voilà les amis je suis en train
d'attendre le sonnet du maroc est restée
là bas mais presque
et ça me permet aussi de vous parler de
ce qu'ils de cathérine star le pain de
sucre sont beaucoup considèrent comme
étant plus grands mathématiciens de
l'otan ce que tu es roundhouse appelle
les trois phases 2
le à pointer jeux mathématiques et
figuration on pense aussi qu'on fasse du
bon travail d'avoir une compréhension de
nos ambitions et de la bonne utilisation
surtout de nos intuitions n'a pas phases
une phase assez la phase pré rigoureuse
c'est ce qu'on fait à l'école maternelle
on joue avec des numéros avec des
figures géométriques
mais ce qui marche et les trucs qui
marchent pas on sait pas pourquoi mais
c'est les maths que l'on fait et pendant
très très longtemps y compris je pense
au lycée le très très très gros des
maths c'est juste des modes très
rigoureuse saisir sans rigueur et pour
moi ça a changé notamment au lycée avec
la démonstration pour les lakers qui
était un peu une révélation notamment
confié des sommes télescopique pour moi
elle sonne télescopique souvent le
professeur voilà le disait ça se
télescoper et ça a marché
n'y avait pas de preuves rigoureuse
c'est quand j'ai découvert la
démonstration pour la concurrence
j'ai commencé à comprendre qu'ils ont
fait tout les mathématiques pouvait être
rendue aux rigoureuses bien sûr la passe
très rigoureuse des mathématiques
c'est pas le lycée c'est plus la prépa
ou des études supérieures sont plus
générale donc en sa défense d apprendre
des fonctions formelle que permet plus
de dire aussi grand que l'on veut
extraire ceux qui veulent rien dire en
fête et à ce moment là on rentre dans
une phase rigoureuse on essaie de tous
nous toucher
cependant pour carrington cette phase
rigoureuse et ultra est indispensable à
l'apprentissage mais c'est sage
rigoureuse elle est aussi inadaptée à
une vraie compréhension des
mathématiques et en particulier la
recherche en mathématiques et du coup il
faut passer ensuite à une phase pré post
rigoureuse sur est mon cas on commence
vraiment à jouer votre avec nos
transitions mathématiques en parallèle
avec la rigueur mathématique mais en
particulier à ce moment là il ya
beaucoup de résultats en mathématiques
que l'on va un traité que l'on va croire
bien avant de se mettre à vraiment les
prouvé mathématiquement tout cas j'y
suis le sommet de du maroc montcouquiol
qu'elle a dit unis 6 4 967 une faune 64
m hier donc la phase post très heureuse
d'un terrain jusqu'à ou parle ça veut
dire quoi concrètement ça veut dire que
la plupart des raisonnements ce fut
essentiellement de façon utile et c'est
comme ça que ça se passe au niveau de la
recherche
si vous faites c'est de trouver quelque
chose qui va faire trois pages de
preuves vous pouvez pas être précis dès
le début
d'ailleurs vous avez d'abord travaillé
avec les intuitions et eux et c'est
seulement une fois que les intuitions
sont claires avec elle qu'elle donne une
idée très précise de là où est ce qu'on
s'en va et est ce que mon parti tu l
faut des comptes dentition qui soit
quasiment sûrs autant que possible c'est
à ce moment là qu'on va se mettre à
déployer tous les arsenaux table
l'arsenal des de la preuve mathématique
bronze mais d'une certaine manière la
preuve bourreuse mathématiques n'a pour
but non pas de trouver ou de certifier
faisceau swan mais c'est plus un 16-2
sanity tchèque c'est plus pour vérifier
qu'on ne fait pas d'économies comme le
disait grotte indique annonce ayant pas
d'association exact de grosses sommes
qu'elles durent pas trop le pas trop
attaquer ici mais alors ce que disaient
les crottins dit que c'est quelque chose
comme il faut d'abord à être
parfaitement convaincu faut trouver
d'abord la chose évidente
avant de commencer à eux aussi de les
trouver en partie
j'aime essayer de prouver quoi que ce
soit qui n'a pas aller encore évident et
du coup là vous sentez bien que tout le
jeu est maintenant tous buté
mathématiques au final cas si on suit
les pas de poincaré chronique ou encore
keren stable c'est surtout d'essayer
d'affiner à chaque fois en question que
l'on aa désole m
cook est de certifier tout cela de
mettre un tampon sur la validité de
notre intuition
quand on sent que c'est par ac caire et
à son maître est une preuve mathématique
mais dans une fois de mathématiques
s'ils ont plein de détails qui vont être
rejetés parce que c'est ce genre
prononcé je trouve ton ailleurs qu'une
amplement les autres lisent et à ce
moment là c'est à ce moment là une fois
mathématiques et à c'est avant tout une
façon de convaincre les autres
mathématiciens et on les convainc en
essayant de montrer que les intuitions
serra charentais sont suffisamment
évidentes pour qu'il puisse être capable
d'en écrire la preuve s'il de librement
de vérifier qu'ils 360 encore et c'est
pour ça que nos enseignants de recherche
la laque et première question qui est
posée c'est jamais est-ce que la preuve
juste c'est toujours calé l'intuition
derrière ces résultats en mathématiques
parce que l'intuition est beaucoup plus
importante
il faut qu'on arrive à raisonner avec la
bonne intuition on peut aller bien plus
loin en particulier quelque chose à
travailler c'est l'intuition pour
laquelle l'intuition est bonne je fait
il existe des preuves mathématiques
souvent va corroborer une certaine porte
d'intuition même si en général ça va pas
prouve exactement la bonne intuition
mais ça va juste la corroborer et puis
de même manière un truc très utile en
domotique ces exemples comme le dirait
david hilbert tu es les mathématiques se
résume souvent à trouver le bon exemple
qui à la fois suffisamment simple pour
être compris docile suffisamment
représentative d'un phénomène plus
général et du coup raisonner avec ce
genre d'exemple c'est typiquement
quelque chose que notre intuition va
pouvoir faire très facilement très
rapidement pour pouvoir comprendre
l'ensemble des objets qui ne sont pas
exactement ces degrés l'homme descend
maintenant du violon dingue acier et
donc et cette histoire de postes
rigoureux post rigueur de phase post
rigueur de la réflexion malheureusement
c'est un truc qui n'a aucun sens pour ce
qu'ils sont j'avais connu la rigueur
malheureusement je crois et
malheureusement ça aussi très bon sens
pour ceux qui sont encore en phase
rigoureuse où il cherche à toujours être
rigoureux par
partout ils se rendent pas compte que
pour aller très loin
recherche en mathématiques et dans la
compréhension des mathématiques en
général on peut pas passer trop de temps
à justifier les bases rigoureuse et on
est obligé de 1 peut admettre des trucs
qui sont clairement vérifié par notre
intuition et c'est pour ça que par
exemple la fin des à l'intérieur des
articles de recherche parfois et il ya
des phrases comme il est clair que vous
il est évident que c'est pour faire
parler davantage l'intuition que la
rigueur et ça ça al'avantage de
raccourcir les preuves et surtout de
donner une vue d'ensemble des preuves
parce que malheureusement trop souvent
notamment au niveau prépa on s'enferme
dans la rigueur enfin faire dans toutes
les étapes qu'a joué on perd de vue le
big picture ce qui est une bonne chose
en fait pour un mathématicien grande
échelle quoi bon on pourrait croire que
du coup on est revenu au point de départ
puisque avant compter sur l'intuition
maintenant on compte encore sur
l'intuition en dans la phase post
rigoureuse en fait on a beaucoup avancé
on peut l'avoir particules à grosse
différence entre la phase pré rigoureuse
et la phase post rigoureuse c'est que en
phase post rigoureuse normalement on
sait pourquoi est ce qu'on prend ce que
l'on pense ou comprend l'origine de nos
intuitions et par conséquent on est
capable de donner un certain degré de
fiabilité
à chacune des intuitions que l'on a et
c'est vraiment ça je pense la clé pour
pouvoir bien réfléchir il faut avoir des
bonnes intuitions et pour avoir des
bonnes intuitions
il faut être passé par une phase
rigoureuse où on cherchait vraiment à
chaque fois à dire pourquoi est ce qu'on
pense ce que l'on pense malheureusement
cette phase rigoureuse il ya très très
peu de gens qu'ils ont et je pense que
sur des sujets un peu plus petit comme
la politique les gens sont jamais passés
par cette phase on vous invite à port
récapituler un peu tout ça est ce que
c'était pas très clair une vidéo un
petit peu improvisée
je perds cas pas trop devant ce nom
séverine vietnam merci bonjour et
bienvenue vous invite à récapituler un
peu cela est fort scène ce qui a été un
petit peu pas super bien préparé je puis
je suis désolé que met donc ce qu'il
faut retenir de ce match fort scène
c'est surtout que les intuitions c'est
un atout pour réfléchir c'est même
indispensable le poids vie chère je sais
pas comment on peut à bien réfléchir
sans anti sion
malheureusement le brent c'est que bien
souvent les intuitions que l'on a
eh bien on sait même pas d'où elle vient
et en fait il ya même des origines
génétiques à la presse notamment des
rochers à des recherches par jonathan
wright ou par steven pinker si vous
trouverez non steve hooker steven flickr
bien sûr si on ne connaît pas l'origine
dans un pays où on est incapable de
savoir si on peut leur faire confiance
donc un gros travail indispensable à
faire sur les intuitions au préalable
c'est de savoir quel est le degré de
confiance que l'on doit attribuer aux
différentes intuition et pour cela le
mieux c'est encore de savoir d'où est ce
que vienne essayait de de trouver
l'origine des intuitions et une fois
qu'on connaît les héros d'un jeu les
origines des intuitions on peut même les
améliorer les affiner ou compléter les
intuitions avec d'autres auditions
complémentaires comme c'est souvent le
cas en mathématiques on aime voir les
objets sous différents aspects du coup
on aime avoir plusieurs intuition
différentes d'un même objet par exemple
un vecteur il ya pas mal de façon de se
représenter 28 tivement si un truc à
retenir de cette vidéo c'est que les
intuitions c'est pas quelque chose de
fatal
ils movie immobile les intuitions c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut nourrir et
modifier mettre à jour au fur et à
mesure et pour ceux qui connaissent
savent bien sûr tout ce que je suis en
train de vous raconter la semil travail
et lyon je suis parisien donc c'était ma
force et ça vaut ce que ça vaut elle
vous invite à mettre vos avis dans les
commentaires
paysages
[Musique]